the first public response to a very
public attempt to undermine Brazil's
Democratic institutions
many thousands of people gathered in Sao
Paulo the country's most populous city
to repudiate Sunday's assault on the
presidential Palace Supreme Court and
Congress buildings in the capital
Brasilia like almost everyone here
Eliana blames former president Jade
bolsonaro whom she believes was The
Mastermind of the attack
he must be jailed for all the things
he's done in this country he promoted
militia thieves attacks on the Amazon
blacks gays and now this we won't let
these fascists pass never again
earlier police detained and began
questioning more than 1500 Pro bolsonaro
activists suspected of taking part in
the assault the camp they'd set up
months earlier just eight kilometers
from the presidential Palace has been
demolished they'd echoed bolsonaro's
unfounded claims that electoral fraud
stole his re-election last year
the Justice Minister says the culprits
were hoping to inspire a nationwide
Revolt but failed in their attempt to
overthrow president Lula da Silva who'd
been sworn in just a week earlier
we've witnessed a Brazilian version of
the U.S Capitol Building attack but with
two differences first no one died and
secondly we have more people under
arrest here than in the U.S and very
quickly
the investigation into who financed and
led the raids is just beginning
We Believe many big business interests
paid for the buses to bring those coup
mongers to Brasilia and set up camps
those businessmen need to be
investigated and punished
demonstrators here also wanted to show
that the president is not alone
they're also saying that they will not
tolerate an amnesty for any of those
people who have already been arrested
whom they are calling terrorists and
cool mongers but the Justice Minister
says that for example there's no
possibility of extraditing the former
president bolsonaro from the United
States where he is right now because he
hasn't been charged with anything at
least not yet
whether the newly installed president of
Latin America's largest democracy will
be strengthened or weakened by the
unprecedented attack is still far from
Clear Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Sao Paulo